la base quand il est tombé et tout est
assez souple à spa ce qu'il m'a dit je
lui ai dit que moi quel geste culturel à
des essais sur place 10 à peine âgée et
s'aménager puisqu'il est laissé sur
place mais moi je suis pas inquiet
allez je suis allé chercher leurs
sculptures peut-être pas dans les 10
minutes j'ai tenté de nager de scooters
et tout donc je me suis on s'éloigne on
s'est perdu et c'est au moment quand
j'ai commencé à paniquer parce que
j'étais l'aurait et que voilà j'avais
plus de souffle que je me suis dit bon
je laisse aux coutures c'est du matériel
dont j'aurai tout en live à la neige
puis ça s'est passé 11 et vous ça vous a
pris presque une heure pour arriver à
toucher terre parce que ça veut dire
on va diminuer voilà ça a pris du temps
vous êtes arrivé sur un récif où sur un
dilemme je suis arrivé sur l'île et sur
un dit d'accord les gens rencontrés y
avait monsieur là le soir souligné un
bateau je lui ai dit de me ramener ont
construit des petits pieds un bateau
sous lui j'ai un pote qui t'ont gallou à
ce moment là il m'a amené pour les
rencontrer et il avait déjà donné la
lotte quand il avait dû couper un
disparu
donc ça faisait déjà peut-être parce
qu'une loque il avait d'ailleurs dit
n'allez même 45 minutes kelly avait déjà
donné la latitude